we don't talk to a lot of actors on the
show honestly most of them hate us and
would never come on
but even those who would come on aren't
that interesting when you talk to them
when they're not reading a script they
don't have a lot to say
sad but true christiane is not that
person at all
christie alley has been in films and on
television for 40 years
when she has no script in front of her
she has a lot to say more than we even
imagined
it was an amazing conversation went on
for about an hour on tucker carlson
today
it's on fox nation here's part of it
[Music]
four years ago i was on a set and i
spoke up i didn't know it was going to
be some big deal you know i think i'm
going to vote for trump
oh my god some of the producers took me
aside and go i'm going to too but if i
if anyone hears me say that i will never
work again especially for this
group and i was like what so it was a
little bit ignorance
do you know take it seriously when they
said that that they would be fired
yeah i knew they would be oh wow i i
when they first said it i thought right
who cares
right then in the last four years i've
seen like right who cares because people
go you're so brave i go no i think i'm
stupid because
honestly it is a real situation
it is a real and it is a real
blackballing situation and it's
so strange to me because artists
are free thinkers for the most part yes
do you know and they all think
differently in my whole career
you know let's say when i did cheers
everybody was different yes
they had different political views they
had different that's what made everyone
interesting
so i this whole thing is just psycho to
me i don't
so it wasn't that way i mean people were
liberal or gave the democratic party but
there was a freedom
of thought and expression that allowed
artists to create right i'm not saying
we never say like on cheers i think
there was only like one of the cast
members that was
going to vote republican and i remember
us all going like well he's crazy so of
course he's going to vote
right you know we but it was like who
cares did you try and kick him off the
show or
no we didn't try to get him fired but
there weren't any of those kinds of
things you know
in most of my career you know guys doing
blow and you have guys in rehab and
they're not kicked off
women tend to get kicked off shows more
if they're
doing drugs and with prostitutes
you know men get like 12 chances yeah
and that
that's the only thing i can say about
show business was women
may get one chance if they're lucky and
men get
12 or 15. but that's such an interesting
point that it's endlessly tolerant of
certain people's
deviation from the norm their
eccentricities their drug problems
sleeping with the wrong people no that's
kind of fine
no you can be cooking math and sleeping
with hookers
yeah but as long as apparently
you didn't vote for trump so it's
you know i feel like i'm in the twilight
zone a bit in the
wit with the whole concept of it because
i
you know an example is on twitter i had
many celebrities followed me
and now i think like three follow me so
it's they actually took you off the list
they unfollowed you oh yeah
and i am going i'm the same person you
know i'm the girl who voted for obama
twice right and i'm like oh so you liked
me when i voted for obama and now you're
this and it sort of had me
it's made me have to rethink
weirdly my whole friendships
i just started watching certain things
in the world
like i wanted simple things i'm i'm not
you know a rocket scientist i was like i
want
people to have jobs i want people to
have
you know i'd like gas to cost less money
i'd like
people to have good schools and
just really common sense kind of things
so when i would listen when i was
listening to trump say what he was going
to do
i thought well you're saying you're
going gonna do what i think
we should do he's he's not like mr drug
drug do you know what i mean
yeah he's not mr pharmaceutical he's not
and i have my own views on what's going
on in our country
and how many artists we've lost to
fentanyl and other drugs and
i was sitting right in front of our
faces so i felt like
i like to give this guy a chance so his
firmness on drugs drugs kill people
they're obviously hurting the country he
said that out loud
he said the form of you know like why is
everybody doing drugs now
why is everybody on pharmaceuticals
what's such a great question
why why why are we all suddenly mentally
ill why
why we aren't and if we it's not that i
don't agree that everything and this is
he may say this or he may not i don't
know i want to put words in his mouth
but it's not like
it's not like depression doesn't exist
it doesn't it's not like postpartum
doesn't exist it's not like anxiety
doesn't exist
it's what do you do about it that's
right so in my
universe it's what do you do about it
and my i i said something on twitter the
other day i said let's stop drugging
everybody it was like oh are you a
doctor
and i thought do i have to be a god i
really want to cuss right now
i want to say that i want to say so bad
do i have to be an
effing doctor to not want to take a
million pharmaceuticals or
how about if i'm depressed i find out
why do i have to have a disease wait
find out why
yeah if i'm anxious why
it's like when i did coke i was anxious
all the time duh
i was drugging myself to death
as are many well apparently former
president trump
watched the entire hour we think it's
worth it
hope you do it's as simple as going to
foxnation.com